Dark Phoenix is out and as of this
taping is rotten at 23% the lowest score
for an x-men film in franchise history
yikes but is it really that bad worse
than even x-men origins Wolverine we got
some work ahead of us
let's talk hi everyone I'm Mark Ellis
and welcome to the after show so good to
be back with you this is a spoiler heavy
show so if you've not yet seen the movie
you have been warned
joining us today is one of our all-time
favorites you know her as the host of
the YouTube channel geek bum Maude
Garrett is back with us I am very
excited to have you and joining us live
via Skype from payor weight it is
Sharonda williams hello Sharonda what
part of the world are you in I am in
Atlanta Georgia Atlanta oh hi hi it's a
little more temperate here in the studio
as of right now but that tends to change
when this next gentleman enters the
building that would be the one the only
mr. movie early States himself Scott
movie mance how are you bud I'm doing
great
what an introduction how do you top that
great to see all of you thanks so much
well you say how do you top that I think
that's what x-men Dark Phoenix is
wondering about right now because
there's been a lot of great x-men movies
in the franchise thus far is Dark
Phoenix competitive with those is it on
the other end of the spectrum is it one
of the worst x-men movies we've seen so
before we get into our detailed spoiler
every review I just want to go around
the room and start with you Scott do you
think that this is a fresh movie or a
rotten move oh it is rotten it is rotten
but what you're talking about the worst
x-men film you know that includes he got
the Wolford 3 Wolverine movies even the
Deadpool films two of them they are part
of the x-men Cinematic Universe so
that's 12 movies I think that that above
them all x-men origins Wolverine is the
worst but is Dark Phoenix a bad comic
book movie well you know that's
debatable I've seen worse it's not great
it's not terrible could have been better
so you're saying it's a rotten movie
Sharonda I want to throw it to you next
is this a rotten movie in your eyes as
well
um yes definitely a rotten movie without
a shadow of a doubt
Rhonda's going rotten Scott's going
rotten Maude can you defend this film I
really want to I wanted to so bad I
wanted to love this movie especially
because it's the final arc and like the
Fox only x-men franchise but before
Disney is going to take over it's rotten
guys it's rotten but it's not the worst
x-men movie
I am shocked right now we have three
rottens on the panel my the only one
that's gonna defend this film and say
it's fresh no I'm not now again I'm
gonna echo some of ya'll sentiments
right off the bat is that I don't think
that this is a terrible movie I just
felt like it was very bland it was very
dull there wasn't a lot of life in the
movie and I wanted that from an x-men
film I was a huge fan of the comics
obviously I'm a big fan of the movies
and this one just let me down so as we
get into our first topic here is this
the worst x-men movie in the franchise
Sharonda I'm gonna let you lead off here
because we've had x-men apocalypse like
I mentioned we had the Wolverine Origins
movie which not a lot of people dug we
had The Last Stand which somehow is 58%
almost fresh on the rotten tomatoes
tomato meter so Sharonda is Dark Phoenix
the worst of the bunch no and I did I
hate the disrespect that Dark Phoenix is
getting it's kind of just you know when
the trailers came out everyone just
wanted to make this a horrible movie
before anyone actually has a chance to
see it but no nothing will ever top
x-men origins Wolverine well what are
the biggest issues in Dark Phoenix for
you personally because again you did say
was a rotten movie so what really stood
out to you for me is just with the x-men
franchise as a whole is just the
portrayal you know of Jean Grey of the
Dark Phoenix and you know you kind of
had this glimpse of hope at the end of
apocalypse where you felt as though okay
they're going to take on this saga
they're going to do it right but I've
never seen a film about someone who was
almost a supporting character Capone
don't get to learn anything about gee
you don't really get to dive that much
deeper into Jean Grey that any movie
really has done you know throughout this
franchise and what
again um you're given stories of Raven
of Erik and Charles and it overshadows
who were supposed to be focusing on and
that is Jean Grey that's one point
markets on did you agree with that is
that the movies called Dark Phoenix yeah
we seem to be focusing on everybody else
besides Jean Grey I feel like the last
couple of x-men movie movies want to
focus on whoever is so hot right now
they had Jennifer Lawrence in a contract
so they made mystique all of a sudden
this eccentric character when she's
always you know sort of been a villain
on the side and I think that's happening
again here Game of Thrones is so big
they've got Sansa Stark herself here but
so fotona even though her acting was
incredible I really saw a lot of light
and shade what she brought to the table
acting wise but when you pair her up
against a villain that has absolutely no
point behind it and no motive you kind
of get a little bit lost and it is like
the first two acts you just like why do
I care so is this the worst of the x-men
movie to you nay it is not who earns
that distinction yeah I'm gonna go I
agree with Sharonda here where Wolverine
the origin movie and apocalypse was
worse than this okay see look I I
thought apocalypse was better than this
movie for sure I got to now with the
with origins Wolverine here's what I
will say I really liked seeing Hugh
Jackman as Wolverine even when he has
like Roger Rabbit animated claws that
don't look realistic at all are you
gonna say that this is worse than those
two movies no okay so so first time with
you x-men apocalypse gets a bad rap it's
not the best x-men film but it's
certainly not the worst I mean I think
we all agree that x-men origins
Wolverine from 2009 is the worst but the
other two Wolverines are really good
especially the third one - Bret - by
James Mangold Logan here's the problem
with Dark Phoenix and you said it you
touched an already mark when you said
that it's bland it's tired so much about
Dark Phoenix feels obsolete now if this
movie had coming out let's say 2004-2005
five years after the original film from
2000 I think it would have felt
different but we've seen these superhero
movies grow and evolve over the years
exact story before we've lost and I feel
we see that Dark Phoenix storyline
before
do you think that was handled better in
this movie than it was in the last now
when they last stand that's another
movie from 2006
it's another film that sorry but the
raise it gets a bad rap this is the film
after 2 X minutes that were directed by
Bryan Singer so then the third movie The
Last Stand is directed by Brett Ratner
it's not as good as the first two it's
like it's like the two it's like The
Return of the Jedi of the series not as
good as its two predecessors but it
still stands on its own terms
in terms of titles for Dark Phoenix
instead of x-men first class which was a
terrific film right it was energetic it
was vibrant it was fresh this movie
should have been called x-men third
class sheer honest gods getting a lot of
phases out of mod right now okay look
I'm gonna give you one Dark Phoenix
storyline to check out would you go with
x-men The Last Stand or would you go
with Dark Phoenix yes why is that is
that just because it came first because
we had more of our classic x-men feel
what was about last thing that's gonna
put it a notch above dark Phoenix in
your book and last and you get to see
more of genes internal struggle you know
battling the power that's inside not
being able to properly control her
emotions seeing the pain of realizing
you know the effects of when she kind of
switches over and in Dark Phoenix you
don't get to see any of that I mean it's
kind of just like okay I'm bad and
that's it there was some liveliness that
I see an x-men last and that I saw an
apocalypse I even saw the beginning of
origins Wolverine that I just did not
feel in this movie and as we move on to
our next segment I think that that's
what I'm focusing on here from the
negative standpoint is the the acting
performances oh I felt like everybody
just kind of showed up and I know that
people been killing Jennifer Lawrence
for the last couple movies is just kind
of licking a stamp put on the envelope
here's my performance I got the same
thing from sophie turner and maybe it's
just because I felt like I was watching
somebody who hasn't moved on from Sansa
Stark right it's got similar vibes to
Sansa Stark I just didn't get a lot of
life in that performance mod am I crazy
here am I being too harsh I actually
think they act
was one of the better parts of this
movie it was the script that was so bad
they really didn't have a lot to work
with there was no internal dialogue or
like you know moments where they really
had an enriching part to grow and I
think a lot of the times like we've seen
the x-men so much we know these
characters it's their connection and
it's the interactivity with the other
characters that really do amplify them
we're not really getting that here I
mean when you have the Dark Phoenix
thing she had she keeps running away and
so she only has moments to herself and I
think that she's trying to do the best
that she can she had a great moment with
Cyclops ty Sheridan where she's just
like you know broke down into tears and
I really felt that for a moment but then
you realized that she's the only one who
has dialogue her and jessica chastain
the only ones that really have dialogue
and the rest are just the supporting
cast but they're not even like you were
saying Chiron as supporting a main act
they're supporting a supporting
character see I'm with you I felt like
sophie Turner also in addition to
general Jennifer Lawrence in this movie
they did not give inspired performances
because the script as he just touched on
would the script does not inspire
everything about this film feels tired
and obsolete how do you take an
oscar-winning actress like Jennifer
Lawrence won her Best Actress Oscar for
2012 silver linings playbook and make
her look bad
give her a bad script and that's what
happens with this movie and yes I agree
completely with the other points made by
but both of you that that sophie Turner
is a supporting character in her own
film yeah I feel like a lot of the women
got shortchanged in this movie and it
wasn't just sophie Turner and Jennifer
Lawrence I think that Jessica Chastain
Sharada because she's playing an alien I
can give that a pass like you're not
supposed to have a lot of emotion you're
supposed to come off as cold but
Alexandra's ship is storm she had like
two lines in the hole but it was very
disappointing do you pin this more
Sharonda on the performances or on the
script that the performers were given
weren't bad I'm is one of the saving
graces of the film but literally
watching the film and the back of my
mind on replay was just I'm just here so
I don't get fine everyone just like do
the last movie just do what we have to
do it doesn't matter if this is
we don't have child Saxon just any
wedding with the x-men and you could see
that on screen a lot of cringy dialogue
in the film characters to say the things
that they said and then also to as far
as how the women are portrayed I think
that's always been an issue with the
x-men franchise so this point I'm just
accepted and just that's just how it's
going to be but I think for the most
part it's just a bad script it's just so
bad characters that you are introduced
to I'm in the previous film they still
haven't been fleshed out relationship
still haven't been fleshed out between
characters it just doesn't make any
sense they clearly did not try it all
this well can I talk about the fact
there's absolutely with the
relationships between these characters
that we've almost had three movies or at
least two movies to kind of get to know
the last end I actually liked it because
what the Phoenix struggle was she was
too powerful for your own good
this is the first time we heard about
the level class system like a level 5 I
was like so about that because it's
about how strong these powers are and
then you had this love triangle where
Wolverine was so in love with Jean Grey
but she was with Cyclops and then like
sacrificed him and basically killed him
when she couldn't control it and he was
the only one who could save her because
his powers could regenerate fast enough
for her and I was like that was great
but then Cyclops in this did nothing
yeah that was like when I woke up and I
went whoa okay well maybe you're psychic
oh we're all talking about about the
quality of the script which is not very
good the quality of the performance is I
think I more like you mark I noticed it
more than more than both of you did and
I completely agree with how the women
have been shortchanged all along in the
x-men Cinematic Universe so I think the
other thing going on here is us you know
for the last 19 years since the first
x-men opened in 2000 we have seen these
superhero movies grow and evolve x-men
when at the spider-man spider-man went
into the Dark Knight Dark Knight went
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
we've we built up such a tolerance where
these superhero movies have gotten
better and better and stayed friends
ingress Boyken hello
and adventures ain't game and now here's
here's xmin when they come on the screen
and those costumes they they already
look dated and that's part of the
problem it's it's part of the problem
but I also think that just not giving
screens I'm not just to storm but I also
miss the Quicksilver I mean Evan Peters
what a what a standout the Quicksilver
had been and then you talk about that
Quicksilver magneto relationship that
could have been explored and then let's
talk about Magneto and Professor X I
mean Fassbender and McAvoy they didn't
have a lot to do in this movie either so
Sharonda I think it was a mix of all the
characters just not really getting to
show their full potential when we saw
Fassbender and on screen again for the
first time and he's Magneto I was
excited I was like here we go and it
just didn't really move the way I
thought it would yeah I mean
relationship portion of it especially
the Quicksilver and the magneto which
still bothers me because they had
opportunities and apocalypse to kind of
bring this into the forefront and I
thought out for the last film we were
going to explore this but Quicksilver
disappeared oh yeah
one good Quicksilver sequence with some
good music in the background that is
what we show up to see from him my
favorite Quicksilver between both you
know through the regular x-men through
Fox the MCU but also too I I was okay
with not seeing the relationship between
um Charles and Erik cuz I've just seen
it so many times I really wanted to see
the growing relationships coming with
this new class and you know that their
the conversation when they're having
this discussion I'm Raven and hey
they're just like I think it's time for
EFI we've grown out of all of this and
it's time for us to give them a chance
and we never get to see them yes and
that chance to take over the rain
throughout the course of the film and so
the relationships as a whole is just let
me tell they didn't even try and break I
felt like I went through a bad breakup
like well if we graduated we knew that
we can't make this long-distance
relationship work but like we're gonna
try to stay together over the summer and
no he just left me he just left me and
didn't care that's how I felt while
watching dark meeting can I say one
little thing Alexandra Shipp who plays
storm has gone on record
an interview to say you know because I
was like are you excited about exploring
your character with this Disney Fox
merger and she said well why so I can be
in another ensemble movie and be
sidelined and literally be a sass an
effing sasquatch in the background of a
shot yeah yeah dorm had really cool
powers in this too she's she's doing the
weather thing but there's so much that
they put in this movie that some folks
are saying is unnecessary and that's our
next point is the aliens that the alien
involvement in here did we need aliens
for this movie Scott did that elevate
the source material and then you have
you know someone like Jessica Chastain
not be able to pull it off again
she's they're all working with that
material and you can all see it and all
of the performances this is a great cast
and acted to say that I did think that
Michael Fassbender's gave the most
inspired performance of the movie he
really made lemonade out of lemons he's
a human but he's a human aliens I mean I
it was a part of the storyline that I
felt like it was a very very
underdeveloped backstory I didn't care
well some people are saying more than
just underdeveloped backstory Chiron is
that it felt a lot like Captain Marvel
and that it was maybe trying to echo
Captain Marvel and we're looking at
aliens are these scrolls did you get a
lot of that Fox kind of mimicking what's
going on with the MCU right now even
though this movie was shot like two
years ago what is going on am i confused
that I missed the plot of the story why
are we doing this the aliens were so
unnecessary for this film I was just and
I really felt as though this is another
reason why they could have taken the
time to explore some of the new mutants
that we actually had a chance to see in
the film that were just in the
background just taking up space I don't
know they're gonna get to see new
mutants either in this book or the
actual new mutants book themed flawed
because that movie keeps getting delayed
- when you look at Jessica Chastain and
you look at what a fantastic actress she
is and then being put into a role where
she's just playing this
motionless alien I liked the idea of
having aliens in this movie and from the
first sequence when we got to go to
outer space I was like oh cool now we're
gonna have this threat that we have to
fan together and solve and it just felt
like it devolved from that yeah I
actually didn't like the alien aspects I
think that when we go into an x-men
movie we want to celebrate all of these
mutant powers and that and how you weave
in and out of that I think you know the
whole premise of that is you're born
with this ability that you didn't ask
for and you have more power than you
know what to do with and do you use it
for good or do you use it for bad it's
kinda like the Chronicle aspect of it
all huh no no we're saying with bright
bone at the moment that's why we watch
x-men movies I don't think we watch it
for aliens and if you're gonna bring
aliens into it I need to know why
they're here what they really do want
not just I want to obliterate this
planet and take it over it's like
there's it's just not really working and
then you're like oh maybe Jessica
Chastain's character is supposed to
influence or guide we'll be like a dark
force and get in her mind but that
doesn't really happen either and it
feels like the villains get in the way
of what could have been a really great
storyline it's very hard with the aliens
this middle part of the film yep the
cardinal sin of this x-men film is that
it's boring it was boring I was it is a
movie it is a lifeless film it is a
movie without a pulse it is boring I
would say it's boring in some places but
there are other parts of movie that
actually did really find myself enjoying
in the theater direct those would be the
action sequences yeah the action
sequences I thought the train scene was
really cool I liked the Armory's that's
like a callback to the first x-men but
Nightcrawler had a lot of neat stuff to
do and even storm even though she get to
talk a lot she had cool powers that she
got to showcase Chiron I want to kick
off with you with this segment I like
the action sequences and I thought that
they added something to the movie which
is why I probably don't completely hate
it how did you feel about the way the
action sequences and the set pieces were
pulled off for parts of the film really
the first and second half of the film I
felt as though there needed to be more
action especially the scene where
they're in this Street it's just
everyone is in such close quarters and
it's all moment I know that they were
trying to convey the chaos that they
were wreaking you know in this town
when it was too much to even keep up
with who's doing what the only thing
that truly saves this movie is the train
sing magneto he did that that's great
yes pull all the gums up again I had a
really big flashbacks of the original
x-men movies where they had to make
everything plastic because if there's
one x-men that's the threat that you see
how you have to change the normal
day-to-day to coexist with dangerous
x-men we kind of lost that and Dark
Phoenix the whole point of it is that
immediately she's so dangerous and all
of a sudden they have to contain her but
it's like she barely even really did
anything - she was barely in the film
and what that last train sequence act
three yeah that was a great scene but it
came too late it didn't save the movie
what nearly didn't exist that wasn't the
first go of the movie they should we
shot that entire last act it was
supposed to be up in space but they were
scared that I was looking too much like
up to Captain Marvel so they kept it to
the the earth again but that was all new
and you can almost tell that because
two-thirds of the movie you're like
what's gonna happen what's gonna happen
then all of a sudden action and it's
like wow this is what I wanted fried oh
yeah yeah and it just felt like a
different movie because it is so
different movie it was filmed later yeah
how about that New York Street Bell of
those Sharonda I thought I thought there
was there are some nice sequences in
there where we got it because magneto
like pulls the subway up and you had
that I'm not really sure what the knife
lady what her like special ability was
other than having a lot of knives which
is still cool so and she has telekinesis
telepathy she can drain those the life
force she's just like I can control
minds - with Nightcrawler only why she's
such a cool character didn't I think
it's probably why I forgot what her
ability was who's like she you're kind
of like the other person and but you
have knives and that's what I'm
remembering Scott listen I I get the one
scene that sticks out in this movie you
know I mean yeah the New York scene was
good
the last scene was great and now it
makes sense I'd know that they thought
that last scene and it maybe it did save
the man but that space mission in the
beginning I thought was neat when it was
Nightcrawler
night crawls his way in to save the
astronauts again between after seeing
and I know this was shot a while ago but
after seeing Captain Marvel and Avengers
endgame this felt it paled in comparison
it felt very similar and not as good as
those two films all right well look I
only have so much breath left and I'm
not gonna waste of all defending this
movie I also thought was pretty rotten
so Scott I'm gonna put all the pressure
on you right now first after then we'll
get to some on and Sharonda with this
question what should Marvel Studios
think see you do finally the x-men how
do the x-men move forward do you put
them into the MCU and pepper them in and
post-credit scenes or do you announce a
standalone movie and reintroduce the
x-men I've been waiting for this moment
I've been waiting for you to ask this
question I think we are all excited to
touch on this not just us but everyone
the first thing that came to everyone's
mind when Disney announced they were
going to buy Fox they all want yes x-men
in the MCU
let's go so here's the first thing they
should do now that Kevin Feige hat
president of Marvel Studios has
acknowledged that the x-men will be in
the MC and he also said is gonna take
some time he said it could take four to
five I guess what that is the best thing
that they could do what let it let it
let it go away for a while
let the x-men just simmer let people be
hungry for it again let it let it let
people you know get excited for an X
myth um that's the first thing that's a
nice way of saying let the stink of Dark
Phoenix yeah but if it should go away
for a while it should it should just
look like rest and and and you know make
people hungry for it again just like
with the with the Star Trek feature
films you know the last movie was 2012
and then and then you had or I'm sorry
2002 and then when when the 2009 movie
came out people were excited for it so
that's what should happen the second
thing that should happen with the MCU
Marvel movie is they should make a
standalone film everyone wants to see
Marvel's you know x-men vs. the Avengers
it's going to be a very long time before
that happens because they have to build
up to it but in the meantime they should
make a standalone film and they should
make it only with female x-men
Eck's women what's this focus do one
film just focus on an all-female
superhero x-x-x universe well start with
women here right I think one of the best
lines in this movie Maude is when
mystique says it should be called X
women yeah the dudes have had their shot
with x-men do you think it's time to
rebrand x-men in that way as introducing
them to the MCU I think the only thing
enticing about that notion is the fact
that you know we get to see some of the
characters from the original 90s
cartoons that we never got to see
properly done like rogue I mean I'm not
against seeing a new Wolverine who's
actually 5 foot 8 and he's stockier as
well but I do think you know we are so
excited when we know these characters so
well how they're going to interact with
other Marvel members but we need to
clean the slate yeah the timeline is so
convoluted at this stage that that just
needs to unwind itself as well but I'm
all about the recast I just want to see
rogue properly I want to see a team-up
with gambit I want to know what those
interpersonal relationships are like
because that's so exciting for me for
x-men well Marty bring up the most
enticing notion of all for me and I
think for a lot of fans and we want to
hear your comments on this too is the
characters you're most excited to see
interact from the x-men from the MCU all
hanging out together but Sharonda how do
we get the x-men properly into the MCU
because there is going to be some sort
of timeline fudging you have to do right
because it's not like these mutants
existed in this New York school and they
just weren't ready for all these battles
that the Avengers fought so you do like
a multiverse timeline thing here what's
your approach I mean it's kind of
picking and piggybacking off of mine
with rogue is I would love to see the
interaction with rogue and Captain
Marvel only up on the screen you know
Road kinda consumes Carole's power
though then for a certain point in time
Carole is actually chilling with the
x-men I think that's a really perfect
storyline to reintroduce like this new
x-men franchise through Disney now loves
the see play out well the other thing is
look at what Sony did but the latest
spider-man movie homecoming
so they didn't tell the origin story
again because quite frankly twice was
enough with Andrew Garfield tub McGuire
so but they also didn't wipe the slate
clean you know they didn't pretend that
the first five spider-man movies didn't
exist they just they just move forward
they use dine men they use I managed the
catalyst point as like you know the
Padawan Master Connor
but they didn't wipe the slate Queen so
when it comes to rebooting x-men for the
MCU you don't really need to reboot it
from scratch you could just move a
little forward but it's okay oh the more
you think about it the more it hurts
well that's why it's just gotta move
forward with it you know I think that's
why the best advice is you do have to
let this sleeping dog live for a little
bit we need to let this bear hibernate
for a good five years and that's what
Kevin Feige had said is that what you
need to let this thing go away and then
we need to develop the MCU because look
there's a lot of questions in the MCU as
well and and how we're gonna move
forward with those characters that we
know but we've also lost some so how are
we gonna pick the pieces up from endgame
and then we'll worry about getting the
x-men and possibly Fantastic Four hey
whoever else I want to see a scene with
my krola
and spider-man so bad oh my god amazing
spider-man 162 spider-man and
Nightcrawler that was an awesome issue
alright so charandas going with a rogue
Captain Marvel meeting maybe mods
thinking spider-man and Nightcrawler
Scott do you have any other matchups and
any other unifications any character
from the x-men that you can't wait to
see how they handle this person in the
MCU when it comes around to it so you
know one thing that was severely missing
from Dark Phoenix even though even if it
was just for like a quick five second
cameo like he had in first class is
Wolverine yeah what are they going to do
with Wolverine as they move forward
obviously they're gonna recast him Hugh
Jackman's done been there done that
that good block recasting that role but
I've I know we're going to wait but I'm
excited and very curious to see what
they did with Wolverine in the MCU and
can we get a Wolverine and Deadpool
buddy team up please well yeah I want to
see Deadpool and Hulk but I think it
about five years gonna be watching an
MCU movie I don't know which one but
maybe there's a post-credits scene where
there's a wheelchair rolling in and you
see the X and it's like we get very
excited that is all to come and
hopefully we'll have an after show to
talk about from that movie whatever that
happens in the meantime that wraps us
here today I want to thank my incredible
panel for talking all things x-men Dark
Phoenix and thank you all for watching
make sure you hit that subscribe button
right now and hit that bell that'll give
you an alert every time we drop a new
after show comment tell us your thoughts
on Dark Phoenix and we'll see y'all next
time on the after show
[Music]